so do you remember the first time that
you fell in love with hip-hop was it
when you were like a kid oh that's a
good question
it is the 50th anniversary
that's a Monumental thing also it's been
the voice of Liberation for so many
people and like brought so many people
together for years the first time I
remember falling in love with hip-hop
being honest was uh I was in fourth
grade and I went to a pizza restaurant
my parents I had a I had a Walkman CD
player oh I had that antique with
anti-skip with a FM radio yeah you were
so cool yeah
but I had this uh I had the the FM radio
on and I was listening to Power 92 in
Chicago number one in the streets shout
out to power 92. and they and they uh
and uh and the DJ says I'm like man we
got this young cat he's out of Chicago
you know him as a producer but he's
about to drop an album and they played
the song called Through the Wire by
Kanye West yeah I wish I could run and
it had the high-pitched Soul sample and
you could hear him like it was just like
a it was a
it was a life-changer moment for me I
just remember being like I understand
this that speaks to me I'm young but I
get it and I and I feel the attitude and
the energy behind it yeah and that was
like that was I feel like a big reason
why I got into making music that's cool
yeah I didn't know that story yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]